a manufacturer of controversies
Dunstan's
planted fake stories hi I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer Friesen TV I'm here with
Ryan holiday author of the new book
trust me I'm lying confessions of a
media manipulator
he's also been a media strategist for
clients like Tucker Max and he is the
current director of marketing for
American Apparel Ryan thanks for being
here
program in your book one of your main
focal points is that vlogs are really
dictating what's news right now and
feeding the top news dogs instead of the
other way around why why do you think
this is the online cycle drives the
offline cycle and the reason for that is
where do if you're a media producer
you're a radio producer you're a
television show host you're a researcher
where are you finding out the things
that you're going to talk about and your
nightly or daily broadcast you're not
out like pounding the pavement like
sitting in some bar like you know
listening for gossip you're on the
internet like everyone else the
mainstream media outlets have sort of
taken on the role of popularizers so
they see what's being talked about on
the internet and then they say hey we've
got a bigger audience we're gonna take
this thing and we're really gonna blow
it up but this is what everyone's
talking about that's what we need to
bring to our users and so what happens
is that things start on the internet for
whatever reason and then the next thing
you know they're on CNN and you make the
claim that because blogs have an
infinite amount of space to fill you
know the bar lowers for what the quality
of their content but because a lot of
the mainstream news outlets have a lot
of their content coming from online as
well isn't the bar lowered across the
board absolutely I mean we we've always
sort of joked about how having to fill a
24/7 cycle makes cable news just talk
about total [ __ ] well what if it was
a infinite cycle and yet like Fox News
can throw up a blog post and depending
on the response to that blog post decide
whether they want to popularize it
through their radio assets through their
television assets through whatever other
means they have you do make it seem like
it's a bad thing but at the same time
there's also an infinite number of
watchdogs for people sitting at home on
their couch instead of just a few people
in the New York Times newsroom though
there are more critics they pale in
comparison to the power of the machine
to just generate ideas and spread
narratives but
doesn't matter because those narratives
take hold online and they spread so fast
that it almost doesn't matter what
someone says an hour later proving that
it's not true but don't you think it
allows more voices to be heard and once
someone is not accountable or credible
anymore people won't read them every day
it's kind of a fresh start on the
internet whoever is publishing the thing
that's the most interesting is what
we're gonna read and click you don't pay
any money to The Huffington Post so they
don't owe you anything and you don't
really owe them anything and they know
that they can get you back after they've
burned you by publishing some other
crazy thing that you have to click so
it's like you read some crappy you know
like naked celebrity slideshow and it
turns out to be like an exaggeration or
not true and you're disappointed okay
you leave but you can't take back your
clicks for starters and then the next
time you see a headline that big
you're probably gonna click anyway
because what's the costs to you it's
nothing it's just a click and they sell
that click to advertisers there's only a
like button there's no dislike button
and that because of that there's no real
loyalty on either side of the equation
and that diminishes the need to deliver
a quality product and let's talk about
your own manipulation yeah if you can
talk about your experience with Tucker
max I've manufactured controversies done
stunts planted fake stories done
everything from edited edit Wikipedia
pages and see how journalists repeat
what they just find on Wikipedia if you
send an anonymous tip that's too good to
be true it's gonna get published because
there's no consequences for it turning
out to be untrue so for Tucker one of
the big things we did was it was a movie
primarily for young adult males what she
doing
I'm talking to the Turtles are they
telling you to show that fat girl -
because that's what they're telling me
to do there are obviously people who
don't like those types of movies so
instead of sitting back and saying okay
we're not gonna be able to reach those
people there they're nonentity in this
campaign we thought like how can we get
those people to denounce the movie and
talk about it and spread the word about
it in a way that makes young adult males
want to go see whatever they're saying
that they shouldn't go see and so part
of the campaign involved like buying
really controversial deliberately
provocative billboards that I went out
and vandalized and then leaked photos of
the blog's real protest generated from
from my fake stunts to the to the degree
in which the Washington Post is Chicago
Tribune both wrote editorials denouncing
the movie the city of Chicago banned our
advertisements feminists in New York
City vandalized the billboards I'm on
that note with experts I mean with the
24/7 news cycle they're always looking
for quote-unquote experts to comment on
their stories do you think this is
allowing for more people to be hurt
absolutely I mean one of the things I
did with the book is there's this
service called help a reporter out and
basically it's like it's a social
network where reporters and journalists
who are and and producers who are
looking for sources post like hey I need
an expert on cats and then someone says
like I'll be your cat expert and then
they they sort of trade they say look
I'll give you information for your story
if you publicize me and whatever I'm
promoting I spent about six months
pretending to be an expert answering
every query that I could and I ended up
being quoted on everything from vinyl
records to boat winterization to
politics to like evolutionary psychology
to fitness and I got quoted on all these
things and no one bothered to check my
identity no one bothered to Google me
and find out that I had written a book
about media manipulation and ended up
getting quoted the New York Times
ABC News The Today Show pretty much
every major name in media uses the
service and they ended up biting on the
fake leads that I was doing you know
you've said a lot of problems but
compared to you know thirty years ago
and we had three
gatekeepers dictating everything we know
which is better I mean don't don't we
have a lot more opportunities now look
there's no question I think it's it's
great that people have access to
publishing in a way that they've never
had before but you know there's the law
of unintended consequences and what
that's done in this case is just make
misinformation a lot easier and we
haven't really we've embraced this new
technology but we haven't erected any
defenses or made any changes or changed
how we how we consume the news how we
believe what we read based on these
changes people want the crappy
journalism I mean that's that's their
choice it's not it's not up to us to say
you can only have this golden story of
course and and I think look there's
certainly a problem with very indulgent
journalism for a while - which is like
journalists writing about things that
other journalists care about and not the
public so there's obviously a mix but
it's it's hard to say that like oh
people only click crap when we only give
them crap and then we it's sort of it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy right
like I think we have to have like a real
frank conversation about what's
happening I think there's so much
cheerleading going on that no one wants
to look at the bads like there's there's
a sort of the old generation of
journalists who just like hate
everything on the internet because it's
like threatens their job and then
there's this sort of like the jeff
jarvis like tech guru crowd who just
loves anything that the internet
produces and it's like look the the
internet one like it's over the internet
is the future of news well now that
that's the case how are we going to run
things Ryan thank you so much for coming
in yeah thanks for every reason TV I'm
Tracy Oppenheimer